sup everyone
we are at cassoulet Michelangelo in
Florence
dalia appearance
we have a beautiful sunset view going
right now there you can see normal a
massive majority we were just there at
the the capella we've been leasing
that's the river you fume it is the
river
it's really nice here
look at the beach
what's up people it's crazy each one of
these people have their own stories
their own minds have formed in from
their genetics but also from their
environment over time so you've had the
family influence them the friends
influence them the teachers the
communities where they grew up how they
grew up etc everyone's complicated it's
the word sonder everyone knows life is
complicated and unique as our own
[Music]
and that's important thing to respect
because people grew up in different
areas we're all human there are
differences of course genetic of course
where we grow up environmental nature
and nurture both full we're all just a
bunch of advanced chimpanzees here on
this planet
Travel is a very inspiring thing you get
to see all these different people from
all these different places
remember saunder everyone's life is
unique and complicated relationships
their parents with their siblings
co-workers with theirs it's important to
pay respect to that nice to be here
thanks for tuning in thanks for watching
sunset yesterday meet collage Dennis son
[Music]